tweeting earlier today Brooklyn Nets
star Kyrie Irving has requested a trade
League sources tell NBA on TNT this
comes in the aftermath of the sides
unable to get an extension done
all right so let's go to Chris Haynes
who joins us live on the telephone for
the latest here our Crystal update us on
this status here before we get into all
the drama surrounding the Nets what led
to Kyrie's team going to the net saying
they no longer want to play for this
team
so last week I had a story with Kyrie
Irving's agent who was his stepmother
Satilla Irvin and she went on the record
you know at that time and said that her
and Kyrie they're trying to get an
extension done and they want to be in
Brooklyn long term and at that point at
that time she said the ball was in the
next court and so for a few days the
Nets were kind of quiet they weren't
receptive to it and so I guess in the
last couple of days
uh they presented an offer and I just
reported this about 20 minutes ago and
this is ultimately what led to Kyrie
Irving requesting a trade I was told
that
um Irvin and his Camp they did not
negotiate after the Nets presented an
offer that was tied to the team winning
the championship so sources said that
that was a big insult
um to Kyrie and his camp and and I was
told the issue was not about money but
just to show you how he feels about the
Nets and you know the stance that they
took him trying to put that stipulation
into the contract I'm told even if the
Nets came back and offered him a full
Max he would not accept it he wants out
so he wants out
Nanette's May oblige they may not does
it appear that there's a market for
Kyrie Irving right now to to give up
something to acquire him
yeah there's a market you know there's
there's three teams as of right now
um I I expect other teams to call in and
inquire but those three teams obviously
the Los Angeles Lakers Phoenix Suns and
the Dallas Mavericks um those are teams
that that have been engaged with the
Brooklyn Nets trying to see what could
potentially get done and I also tweeted
this you know myself as well with the
Phoenix Suns you know you look at some
of the teams that have something to
offer the Phoenix Suns are one a few
teams that can facilitate a deal where
both teams will still be in Championship
Pursuit and so I think with the Brooklyn
Nets they have a little bit of time as
you know we're a little under a week
away from the trade deadline to where
they can trying to Canvas and sift
through the best offers but you know
Sean marks Mark's over there with the
book of Nets he's going to have a a
quite busy time I would be very
surprised if Kyrie is still a net past
the trade deadline all right so so Kyrie
Irving is the third member of the pets
to ask for a trade in less than the last
year
with James Harden last February Kevin
Durant over the summer and now Kyrie
here
the Nets came to some sort of agreement
with KD to get him back into camp this
year any idea where Kevin Durant's head
is right now heading into the trade
deadline less than a week from today
that's where we're all that's what we're
all trying to get a glimpse into what KD
is thinking right now
obviously he hasn't responded to any of
my techs today and understandably so
but I will say this you know that that
is definitely the next puzzle after this
situation where Kyrie is resolved you
have to you have to know I mean for the
Nets I I would think they would be right
now even trying to you know get into
Katie's ears and try to explain what's
going on and try to
to get him to understand that they are
still on the path of trying to compile
pieces to win a title and I I think
that's what most GMS will be doing as of
right now but yeah that's the million
dollar question what is KD thinking
where is his head at because Katie and
Kyrie are awfully tight so you know
that's something we'll have to monitor
after this Kyrie situation is resolved
just real quick one more point of
clarification have you heard from
Kyrie's stepmom or Kyrie directly if the
Nets are unable to facilitate facilitate
a trade by next Thursday's deadline is
he going to be willing to play for the
Nets and finish out this year
that's a good question Jared I would I
haven't been able to talk to um Kyrie or
his um his agent as a yet
you know with things going down right
now I think they're laying low but what
what I will say is that
he has informed the Nets that he will
leave in free agency
if they if he is not traded so with that
being said I I I would tend to think
that he would finish out the season I I
would tend to think he will still uh
cooperate and finish out his contract
but just the way that that was explained
to me with him saying if he's not traded
by the deadline he will walk in free
agency that leads me to believe that he
would finish out his tenure with the
Nets and just vote for free agency all
right good stuff Chris hayne's NBA on
TNT Bleacher Report will continue to
follow the latest with you on Twitter as
we